- Hi, I'm Chase.
I'm in Alachua, Florida.
Let me show you my shop.
[rock music]
My grinders.
This was a custom-made grinder.
My dad and I
put this together.
It's running off
of an old air compressor motor,
so it turns really fast,
takes off a lot of meat.
And then I have
my bench-top grinder.
Pretty heavy-duty stone wheels.
Really good for taking off
lots of material.
A drill press,
which was my grandfathers.
Actually, both of these
were my grandfathers.
These came out of his shop
after he passed away.
So using these
is a pretty cool--
pretty cool thing
to be able to do.
I have a piece of him
in my shop,
and it kinda feels
like he's here with me.
- Hi there, I'm Brandon
from Blackfoot, Idaho.
We're at my shop and I just
wanna give you a quick tour,
show you my cool stuff
I've got.
So, come on in.
I've got
this horizontal grinder.
It's been key
in the construction
of many blades now.
It's one of my favorite tools.
We built it from scratch.
I turn this switch on...
[metallic whirring]
The belt comes on and I can do
all kinds of fancy grooves,
I can replace these wheels
with smaller or bigger wheels.
It works really well.
My main belt grinder,
this here is one
I put together
after getting the frame.
Put the motor on it
and everything.
It's a Coody brand.
I've had it
for a couple years now,
and I really like it.
- I have a turtle hammer.
This is a really,
really cool piece.
Let me show you
how an older school,
non-power hammer works.
It's pretty loud,
but pull this out
to keep the tension
on the springs,
and then you just...
[clangs loudly]
Smack down...
♪ ♪
Really heavy,
but once you get going,
the momentum works really well.
- Right here is
my favorite part of my shop.
It's my favorite tool.
I love it.
It's my 50-pound
little giant power hammer.
It works like a charm.
I mean, everybody knows
how they work,
so I won't fire it up
'cause it's loud as hell.
But it's amazing.
It's--it's my favorite tool.
I love it. I was able to pick
this up last fall.
So that's my shop.
Thanks for checking it out.